Mais, à l'autre extrémité du spectre,
il y a aussi des dégâts,
lorsque les parents pensent que l'enfant ne peut pas réussir
à moins que les parents ne les protègent à tout instant,
qu'ils planent au-dessus de l'action, gèrent chaque situation,
et mènent leur enfant vers un petit nombre d'universités et de carrières.
Quand nous élevons ainsi des enfants,
je dirais « nous »,
car dieu sait qu'en élevant mes deux adolescents
j'avais aussi tendance à faire cela,
nos enfants finissent par vivre une enfance toute tracée.
Voici ce à quoi cette enfance ressemble.
Nous les gardons sains et saufs,
nourris et abreuvés,
nous voulons nous assurer qu'ils iront dans les bonnes écoles,
les bonnes classes dans les bonnes écoles,
qu'ils auront les bonnes notes dans les bonnes classes des bonnes écoles.
Les notes mais aussi les résultats,
mais aussi les accolades et récompenses,
et le sport, les activités, le leadership.
Au lieu de rejoindre un club,
il faut en créer un car cela plaît aux universités.
Cocher la case du service communautaire.
Montrer aux universités que cela vous importe.
(Rires)
Tout cela est fait avec un degré de perfection grandement espéré.
Nous attendons que nos enfants atteignent la perfection
que nous n'avons jamais atteinte,
et, parce qu'on en demande tant,
nous pensons
qu'en tant que parents nous devons nous disputer avec chaque professeur,
principal, coach et arbitre
et nous comporter comme le concierge de notre enfant,
son garde personnel
et sa secrétaire.
Puis, avec nos enfants, nos précieux enfants,
nous passons tant de temps à les encourager,
cajoler, conseiller, aider, marchander, questionner parfois,
afin d'être sûrs de ne pas nous planter,
ne pas fermer de portes,
ne pas ruiner leur futur,
une admission tant espérée
à quelques universités
qui refusent presque tous les candidats.
Voici ce qu'un enfant ressent lorsqu'il vit cette enfance toute tracée.
Tout d'abord, il n'y a pas de temps pour jouer.
Il n'y a pas de temps l'après-midi
car nous pensons que tout doit être enrichissant.
C'est comme si tout devoir, tout contrôle, toute activité
était décisif pour le futur que nous avons en tête pour lui
et nous le dispensons d'aider aux tâches ménagères
ainsi que de dormir assez,
tant qu'il coche les cases de la liste.
Durant cette enfance toute tracée, nous disons ne vouloir que son bonheur
mais, quand il rentre de l'école,
nous commençons trop souvent par nous enquérir
de ses devoirs et de ses notes.
Et il voit sur notre visage
que notre approbation, notre amour,
sa valeur,
viennent de ses 20/20.
Puis nous marchons à ses côtés,
gloussant des éloges comme un entraîneur à un concours canin --
(Rires)
le persuadant de sauter un peu plus haut et de jaillir un peu plus loin,
jour après jour.
Arrivé au lycée,
il ne se demande pas ce qu'il aimerait étudier,
quelle activité l'intéresse.
Il va voir le conseiller et dit :
« De quoi ai-je besoin pour entrer dans la bonne université ? »
Puis les notes commencent à tomber
et il a quelques 15/20
voire même des 12/20,
et il envoie des SMS à ses amis
pour leur demander si quelqu'un a déjà été accepté à l'université avec ces notes.
Nos enfants,
peu importe où qu'ils aillent à la fin du lycée,
ne peuvent plus respirer.
Ils sont fragiles.
Ils sont épuisés.
Ils se font vieux en avance,
espérant que les adultes de leur vie leur aient dit qu'ils en avaient fait assez,
que les efforts faits pendant leur enfance étaient assez.
Ils dépérissent maintenant avec de forts taux d'anxiété et de dépression
et certains se demandent
si cette vie en faudra un jour le coup.
Nous, parents,
nous sommes certains que cela en vaut le coup.
Nous nous comportons
comme si nous croyions qu'ils n'auront pas de futur
s'ils n'entrent pas dans ces universités et n'ont pas ces carrières
que nous voulons pour eux.
Ou peut-être avons-nous simplement peur
de ne pas pouvoir nous vanter de leur futur
auprès de nos amis et avec des autocollants sur nos voitures.
Ouais.
(Applaudissements)
Si vous regardez ce que nous avons fait,
si vous avez le courage de vraiment regarder,
vous verrez que non seulement nos enfants pensent que leur valeur
vient de leurs notes et résultats,
mais qu'en vivant à l'intérieur de leur précieux esprit en développement,
notre propre version de « Dans la peau de John Malkovich »,
nous leur envoyons un message :
« Gamin, je ne crois pas que tu puisses faire quoi que ce soit sans moi. »
Avec notre trop-plein d'aide,
de protection, de conseils, à trop leur tenir la main,
nous privons nos enfants de la chance de développer leur auto-efficacité,
l'un des tenants principaux de la psyché humaine,
bien plus important que la confiance en soi qu'ils ont
à chaque applaudissement.
L'auto-efficacité se construit quand nos actions mènent à un résultat,
pas --
Voilà.
(Applaudissements)
Pas les actions des parents pour l'enfant,
mais ses propres actions mènent à un résultat.
Présenté simplement,
pour que nos enfants développent leur auto-efficacité alors il faut,
ils doivent beaucoup plus penser, prévoir, décider,
faire, espérer, gérer, essayer, échouer,
rêver et expérimenter la vie
pour eux-mêmes.
Est-ce que je dis
que les enfants travaillent, sont motivés
et n'ont pas besoin de l'implication ou l'intérêt des parents,
que nous devrions nous abstenir ?
Non.
(Rires)
Ce n'est pas ce que je dis.
Mais quand nous considérons les notes, résultats, accolades et récompenses
comme l'objectif de l'enfance,
tout cela à la poursuite d'une admission dans une université
ou l'entrée dans une carrière,
c'est une définition trop étroite de la réussite pour nos enfants.
Bien que nous puissions les aider pour une réussite de court terme
en les aidant trop --
ils auront une meilleure note si on les aide à faire leurs devoirs,
ils auront un CV plus long si nous les aidons --
cela a un coût à long terme
sur leur idée d'eux-mêmes.
Nous devrions moins nous inquiéter
quant à quelles universités
ils pourront prétendre candidater ou être acceptés
et plus nous inquiéter de leurs habitudes, leur état d'esprit, leurs compétences,
leur bien-être afin qu'ils réussissent où qu'ils aillent.
Ce que je dis
c'est que nos enfants n'ont pas besoin que nous soyons obsédés par leurs notes
mais que nous soyons intéressés
par le fait que leur enfance leur fournisse une base pour réussir,
bâtie à partir de choses telles que l'amour
et les tâches ménagères.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Je viens de dire tâches ménagères ? Je viens de dire cela ? Oui.
Mais voici pourquoi.
La plus longue étude longitudinale jamais conduite sur l'humain
est l'étude Harvard Grant.
Elle a révélé que les succès professionnels,
ce que nous voulons pour nos enfants,
que les succès professionnels sont liés aux tâches ménagères faites enfant,
plus tôt vous commencez et mieux c'est,
une mentalité où on remonte ses manches et participe,
où le travail peut être désagréable
mais quelqu'un doit le faire, donc pourquoi pas moi,
une mentalité qui dit
que les efforts faits vont améliorer l'ensemble,
c'est cela qui vous fait avancer professionnellement.
Maintenant nous le savons tous.
(Applaudissements)
Nous le savons tous et pourtant, dans l'enfance toute tracée,
nous dispensons nos enfants de toutes les tâches ménagères
et, en tant que jeunes adultes au travail,
ils attendent une autre liste à compléter
mais elle n'existe pas
et, surtout, il leur manque l'impulsion, l'instinct
pour relever leurs manches et participer,
regarder autour et se demander comment ils peuvent aider leurs collègues,
comment ils peuvent anticiper ce dont le patron aura besoin.
Une autre découverte importante de l'étude Harvard Grant
est que, dans la vie, le bonheur
vient de l'amour,
pas de l'amour du travail,
mais de l'amour des personnes :
notre époux, notre partenaire, nos amis, notre famille.
L'enfance doit enseigner l'amour à nos enfants
et ils ne peuvent pas aimer les autres s'ils ne s'aiment pas
et ils ne s'aimeront pas si nous ne leur offrons pas d'amour inconditionnel.
(Applaudissements)
Bien.
Et donc,
au lieu d'êtres obsédés par les notes et résultats
quand notre descendance rentre de l'école
et nous du travail,
nous devons laisser les technologies, lâcher notre téléphone,
les regarder dans les yeux
et les laisser voir la joie qui illumine notre visage
lorsque nous revoyons notre enfant après quelques heures.
Puis nous devons leur demander
comment était leur journée,
ce qu'ils ont aimé de leur journée.
Puis quand votre adolescente, comme la mienne, parle du déjeuner
et que vous voulez parler du test de math,
pas du déjeuner,
vous devez quand même vous y intéresser.
Vous devez lui demander ce qui était si bien pendant le déjeuner.
Ils doivent savoir qu'ils importent en tant qu'humains,
pas à cause de leur moyenne.
Vous pensez amour et tâches ménagères,
cela semble bien joli mais arrêtez cela.
Les université veulent voir d'excellentes notes, des résultats,
des accolades et des récompenses, et c'est en partie vrai.
Les très grandes écoles exigent cela de nos jeunes adultes
mais voici la bonne nouvelle.
Contrairement à ce que nous font croire les classements des universités --
(Applaudissements)
pas besoin d'aller à une des grandes universités
pour être heureux et réussir sa vie.
Les gens heureux qui réussissent ont été dans une école publique,
une petite université inconnue de tous,
l'université communautaire,
ont été dans une université et ont échoué.
(Applaudissements)
La preuve est dans cette pièce, dans nos communautés,
c'est la vérité.
Si nous élargissions notre vision
et considérions plus d'universités,
peut-être soustraire notre propre ego de l'équation,
nous accepterions et embrasserions cette vérité puis réaliserions
que ce n'est pas la fin du monde
si nos enfants ne vont pas dans une grande université.
Et surtout,
si leur enfance n'a pas suivi ce parcours tout tracé et tyrannique
et que quand ils vont à l'université,
quelle qu'elle soit,
ce sera leur propre choix,
motivés par leur propres désirs,
capables et prêts à s'y épanouir.
Je dois vous avouer quelque chose.
J'ai dit que j'avais deux enfants, Sawyer et Avery.
Ce sont des adolescents.
Il y a très longtemps,
je traitais mes Sawyer et Avery
comme des bonsaïs --
(Rires)
que j'allais couper et élaguer soigneusement,
en faire de parfaits êtres humains
qui pourraient être assez parfaits pour être admis
dans une très grande université.
Mais j'ai réalisé, après avoir travaillé avec des milliers d'autres enfants --
(Rires)
et en élevant mes propres enfants,
que mes enfants n'étaient pas des bonsaïs.
Ce sont des fleurs sauvages
d'un genre et d'une espère inconnus --
(Rires)
et mon travail est de leur fournir un environnement nourrissant,
de les endurcir via les tâches ménagères
et de les aimer pour qu'ils puissent aimer les autres et recevoir de l'amour,
l'université, le domaine d'études, la carrière,
cela ne dépend que d'eux.
Mon travail n'est pas qu'ils deviennent ce que j'aimerais qu'ils deviennent
mais de les encourager à devenir de superbes eux-mêmes.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)